try not to let the other person get it
will you catch it good too
look at that ready
kim kardashian and kanye west's
five-year-old son saint is learning from
the best why not on monday kanye shared
this clip of his little boy playing
catch with wait for it football legend
tom brady those are just great moments
you know it's a great part of my life i
think you know things like that are a
lot of fun to do that's the 44 year old
tampa bay buccaneers quarterback tossing
the ball back and forth with saint in
what appears to be a private suite at
the stadium
and get this kanye even offered to
return the favor for tom's kids that's
good you could play uh ketchup my son
i'll draw with your son
i'm a little bit creative
pretty impressive right yay captioned
the clip of his son and the six-time
super bowl champ quote tom and saint
hashtag the home team wins but seriously
saint holds his own against tom who
chats with him about his own three kids
as kanye's song god's plan plays in the
background
all my kids will play catch with me and
then they're like dad
of course tom shares two kids with his
wife gisele bundchen eight-year-old
daughter vivian and eleven-year-old son
benjamin as well as a fourteen-year-old
son john whom he shares with his ex
bridget moynihan
are you a parent that says okay i'm
gonna introduce them to sports and
particularly football or are you letting
them find their own way i think finding
their own way i think you know whatever
things they like to do you know i want
to be able to support them as for saint
who has a cast on his right arm he might
just have a future in the sport you
think tom brady can throw it that far
ah come on
no he only missed that because he had
passed watch out back in september kim
shared that saint suffered an arm injury
posting this message to her instagram
story quote my baby broke his arm in a
few places today i'm not okay having
kids is just there's no way to describe
it but it's a lot as for saints parents
kim filed for divorce from kanye back in
february and a source recently told et
that kim is still quote protective over
her ex the 41 year old kkw beauty
founder has been snapped out on dates
and holding hands with comedian pete
davidson it's a different experience for
sure and e.t source said that she's been
trying to keep her hangouts with pete
low-key because she doesn't know how
kanye will react
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
meanwhile an additional source
previously told et quote kim and kanye's
co-parenting relationship and friendship
changes almost daily depending on
kanye's mood one day he wants to get
back together with kim and the next day
he is blocking her number kim is over
any drama
you